because I heard you talking on a show
where you met Donald Trump yes but not
particularly cause you wanted to know I
was I loved real estate I have to go
meet I was like 11 or 12 and I was going
it was when we were doing press for the
first Potter movie where they took us to
New York and it was the first time doing
sort of the morning shows in New York
and I was about to go on The Today Show
I've never been on sort of American good
morning TV before and it's quite nervous
and Donald Trump was also had also been
on that day and so they did that's
Donald Trump for those of you who have
literally forgotten what he look like
they sort of walked me over to him
because clearly they were like you know
somebody said hey you want to paste
Harry Potter and he was like sure
conversation went but they sort of
walked me over to him and he said I'll
hi nice to meet you and I said nice to
meet you
and I said he said how are you and I
said I'm really I'm quite nervous I died
I've never been on TV before I don't
really I don't know what I'm going to
talk about and he brilliantly just said
you just tell them you met mr. Trump
that is the Everest of self-confidence
if I've just been to you like when you
go on that show just talk about me
Americans and we're both just like like
sad could you do end up talking about
him yeah and you know we should be
talking about the other people
no you're I mean the beauty of the whole
thing is you have to cuz he just doesn't
talk about himself you feel like you
hear you're a big Hillary supporter I
know you've done benefits and yes yeah
yeah yep I am and but you must know the
White House very well because you you
see there's a lot oh yeah I'm there all
the time you play basketball there
something well I I so so I was asked by
President Obama - everyone hates you
already well it was more or less like
you know I just come and sing something
but I got there early because they
offered to give us a tour of the White
House again and you had heard these
these see what you've done with the
place
Wow you've really done a lot with the
kitchen
no so so you'd heard these rumors that
President Obama had his own basketball
court to which I had never heard that
there was even a basketball court you
never heard of me you always heard about
presents playing golf so I was like can
I guys at the basketball court and they
let me go to the basketball court and
the balls have President Barack Obama
stitched it like Spaulding is being no
didn't I asked for one and they said no
so but I was shooting hoops on the on
the court and I was able to have my
manager film me and I made a half-court
shot it only took me like 40-something
tried court shot and then videotaped it
and then I there's a picture I think we
got the picture yeah so I'm actually
showing him because you know I mean you
everything you do there everyone
obviously knows about it I showed up and
he goes our gym we're trying to play a
basketball on my court Brian okay
you know and and then I showed him the
the he I mean can we just talk about
what an amazing president
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you